[Music]
so welcome to the the session on
verification and secure systems so we're
gonna have three speakers than this so
at night and Gayle is going to talk
about a jurors fear and secure hardware
and then Adam chapala from MIT is gonna
be talking about formal methods and how
that drives system design and then
finally nick swami from MSR labs is
going to be talking about the everest
project and verifying TLS so let me go
ahead and turn it over to ed thanks
Chris yes hear me
good morning it's my pleasure to be here
my name's ed nightingale I'm one of the
members of the azure Sphere team this is
a product that was just announced this
spring this talk might be a bit of a
different altitude that I might normally
give at a faculty summit we're really
looking for some engagement with the
academic communities and feedback and I
love to talk to you all later in the day
so and actually right now you can order
development kit if you instrument
playing with the edges of your product
or trying to hack it we'd love that
so what's that just you're focused on as
your sphere is focused all around
microcontrollers microcontrollers are
low-cost single chip computers my
controllers are really in all the
devices around you in your home in your
hotel room at work that you never think
about there are nine billion MCU based
devices built and deployed every year
more than one per person on the planet
and if it has a screen if it has a
button or a low rest screen it's got a
microcontroller in it now what's the big
change about four years ago you started
to see microcontrollers with a radio and
this is in the cost of around a chip
like this is around two dollars and 50
cents so if you said well for two
dollars and 50 cents I can take those
nine billion devices and connect them
all in the Internet
I think the for most of those devices
say obviously we should connect them it
enables us to produce new experiences
needles us to interact with them live
and it kind of new connections with the
people who are using those devices now
the interesting issue is that only about
1% of these MSU devices are connect
right now so why is that well you have
this huge opportunity connectivity and
you also have a large amount of risk
just go through this simple example I
think everyone in this room has used a
refrigerator or has one and the simple
example for connectivity is how do you
know whether the compressor has failed
in your refrigerator well without
connectivity you wake up in the morning
you've got melted ice cream all over the
floor with connectivity and predictive
maintenance you might get a phone call
from your device manufacturer and they
say you know what we've noticed your
compressor is starting to fail can we
stop by and replace it obviously that's
a better experience than the one with
the melted ice cream but what happens
when you connect a device to the
Internet
well we all know what happens we connect
your device to the Internet we've seen
all the stories you've seen baby
monitors that you turn into spying
devices you've some refrigerators that
are sending spam we're seeing ransomware
attacks you're seeing in fact hackers in
fact millions of devices all over the
world I got I saw something the other
day I actually took my router and threw
in the trash because the FBI said that's
what I should do with it because they
couldn't update the software motely
never done that before it's just it's
we're in a space where we have this huge
opportunity for low-cost connectivity
and we have this massive amount of risk
I know a really good example this is the
Mirai botnet from 2016 the Rai botnet
these are just simple IP cameras and it
took down the basically the internet on
East Coast the United States know what's
scary about the Mirai botnet it's only a
hundred thousand devices it's a tiny
number of devices if you look at one
market for connectivity like major
appliances they're about 350 million
major appliances sold every year around
the world a hundred thousand devices can
take down a portion the unit's
infrastructure you know imagine a
billion refrigerators that vault side -
DDoS the other sad thing about this
attack I mean there's well-known
weakness I believe it was a fixed
password the password was shockingly are
OoT you couldn't change the password and
even worse once they saw the exploit
happening there is no way to update the
software on it to get rid of it it was
just a mini disaster another great
example recently is that there is a
connect
thermos thermometer in a fish tank
someone was able to hack it and they
were able to actually use this to bounce
over and attack a database and get
access to high-roller data so you know
we're in the Wild West we're in a space
with IOT where security is an
afterthought what are we gonna do well
the first thing we're gonna do is we
talk about connect TV from each
manufacturers is you know I'm gonna beat
this dead horse you know imagine that
refrigerator you wake up in the morning
but instead of melted ice cream you've
got a text message on your phone it says
we pawned your fridge send us a Bitcoin
or all your ice cream melts you know the
more important one I think is oh you
wake up in the morning and 500,000
stoves have blown up there's actually a
customer we spoke with who had a stove
that was in development and they did a
security audit after we talked to them
they figured out that through a software
exploit
they could turn on the gas in the stove
and an arbitrary amount of time later
they could light it so that did not hit
the market
thankfully they caught that but the
risks are really real the risks are
about physical harm this is foundational
I think everyone in this room knows that
Security's foundational and I think the
issue is really trying to create
platforms where security is comes from
first principles so what's Microsoft
doing about this what is fear all about
well there's two things we want to talk
about one is that so the cost is a night
authored a white paper called the seven
properties of highly secured devices
these properties are measurable now why
do we do this well we felt that there
was no bar someone could look at that
whenever they were looking at an IOT
solution and determine the level of
security that had everyone simply says
you're secure it's black and white as a
single bit everyone in this room knows
that's not how security works this is us
putting a line out there a marker this
is this is the minimum bar any device
that's connected to the Internet should
meet to have the potential be secured so
you have a lot of basics here right you
have a harder route of trust we have
things like defense-in-depth keep your
trust in cubase small certificate based
authentication failure porting and we
will security so this is up on the web
at a kada time of seven properties we'd
love for you guys to read it
feedback about it and have a
conversation about these seven
properties what those properties provide
and why do you think we've hit the mark
there you think that there's room for
more discussion engagement here one of
those important things though is that
someone who's not a security expert at
the very least could take these seven
properties and just ask do I have the
seven properties am I do I have a heart
of your trust in my device do I have
certificate based authentication and if
they don't they can start to ask why not
so that's properties I want to talk in
detail about a couple of them some of
these properties only depend on hardware
support and this is where we're gonna
get into the need for secured silicon in
addition to software and services
classic examples are hardware to trust
it's not affordable cryptographic key
protects the hardware's identity so it
can't be spoofed and implements Hardware
for things like secure boot so we
guarantee the only signed software runs
in a device and you eliminate the
possibility of random malware being
loaded in executed some properties
depend upon hardware and software so
example here's a dynamic compartment
dynamic compartment you could think of
as your MMU that provides out of space
translation and process based isolation
and operating system so net compartments
mean these compartments can change on
the fly you can update them and change
them later and provides a protection
from one process this example not being
it'll take down another one so we'll ask
some of these properties depend upon
hardware software and the cloud so as an
example here we think about renewable
security what does that mean
simply means that we know what tax are
gonna happen we know exploits can be
found does not a device have the ability
to update its software remotely and
securely and this requires cloud to
provide the updates software to apply
that update and hardware to prevent
rollback attacks
what's the rollback attack well robot
attack is a really clever attack where
you have an old version of let's say
sign and legitimate software that has a
known vulnerability and you trick the
device into basically downgrading to a
legitimate but buggy version of the
software so you can exploit it you have
to have support in your heart a room
trust for example in e fuses to be able
to prevent roll back attacks from
occurring so is the properties what's
the product what did we announce as a
sphere is an end end solution
that is proposed of three pillars we
have a just fear calling certified MC
use I'm gonna give you a deep dive of
what a certified MC you means what
properties those embassies have an
operating system and I said security
services so the certified MC you that
provided by silicon partners with
built-in Microsoft security technology
provides connectivity and guarantees are
a dependable hardware to trust the
operating system is secure Microsoft
guarantee we can provide updates for at
least ten years and it provides a
trustworthy platform for IOT experiences
and the security service the security
service brokers trust between devices
and treat devices and the cloud looks
for emerging threats through failure
reporting and allow us for renewable
security I'll talk about that brokering
trust and a little bit so let's get into
what an address pure certified MCU is
could use a term cross over MCU in this
slide all these address for MCS are
connected stay a built in networking
they're secured with this built in
security technology which we call pluton
and it's a cross over and what does that
mean when you look at a typical MCU if
you're in this space you're talking
about something like a cortex-m cortex-m
has physical addressing it lacks a lot
of the properties we're looking for the
crosser miss you we have both the court
to examine in cortex a the cortex a
gives us address space
address translation let's just run a
higher-level operating system like the
width basis something like the linux
kernel has SRAM flash and is protected
by a bunch of we're calling silicon
countermeasures that help guard against
software that ends up being exploited so
plutons the harder to trust what does it
do it guarantees authenticity of your
software so it implants secure booth
you're ECDSA it protects against
downgrade attacks it has the ability to
few fuses protect against an old but
buggy version of software ever being run
in the device protects the authenticity
of device itself so it has its own
cryptographically base identity which
means you can always tell the device
connects whether it is who it says it is
reduces supply chain risk what i mean by
this
it's a great story you guys can look up
out there of a certain
model phone that the one of the
warehouses was physically attacked and
they've routed 52 models of phone and
put malware on it so when these phones
arrived at businesses they came out of
the box with the cameras on and the
microphones recording so having secure
boot guaranteeing that every piece of
software signed eliminating the ability
to have something like a routed or
development mode that someone can
arbitrarily turn on eliminates that type
of risk the pluton and as your sphere MC
use are known about from the time
they're birthed at the silicon
manufacturer so as that ship comes out
of the foundry we know about its
identity we register that ship and then
we can basically know about the chip
throughout its lifetime which means we
can tell what an authentic chip is and
what isn't now it accelerates common
cryptographic tasks like ECC and AES
texting insolent repeat acts so pollute
under the true rate or never generator
it measures its own entropy so it looks
for example you cool the chip down to
try to reduce the space which its
journey random numbers it actually shuts
itself off so that's all about pluton
that was the guarantees it provides a
little bit more detail for this audience
it has a dedicated core and it's owned
TCM memory is that who's this side
channel attacks that focus on a single
core this true random number generator
an elephant plays remote boot and/or
boot measured booty remote attestation
in silicon so uses a digest accumulator
register and a nonce register to allow
us to implement remote attestation with
their services and a look at what
software is actually running on the
device so why do we have a cortex a I
get this question a lot from folks who
are in the MCU space cortex a I simply
bit bigger an area you should end up
using a little bit more memory for you
know what's on there well we think about
security
portability extensibility here so
security basically because we get
isolation cortex and chips don't have
mmm use they don't have address space
translation
having a cortex a allows you to have
process based isolation and what we call
this
seven properties for dynamic
compartmentalization also the special
operating system I'll get into details a
little bit so the OS includes our own
runtime and a custom Linux kernel that's
been focused on the IOT space so as an
example we talked about those default
passwords the azure operating system
doesn't have passwords it doesn't have a
shell it doesn't have user accounts
basically it took a portion of this
space that you typically have with an OS
and just excised it which means we took
that attack surface out of the equation
now of course authentications reviewing
we're doing mutual offer certificate
based authentication and we have our own
author authorization mechanism that's
rooted in pluton to get permissions to
access to hardware resources like
peripherals so this is basic for those
who focus in the OS space and desktop or
server operating systems but having a
address space fertilisation means
application code just gets written once
compiled for and platforms and runs it's
not something you really have an MCU
with a physical addressing you're
typically rewriting and porting your
application to every single MCU platform
that you port so it's a much slower
process for innovation obviously source
portability we have Linux kernel we're
focusing OSS most libraries we have to
support a large swath of the POSIX
standard so you can take a common
process libraries out there and bring
him to the bring them to the platform
and you know with any seven compared to
a it's something like an M for a yellow
or a headroom for the future for
bringing new products to market through
this your software update so what are
these firewalls when I say the term
firewall I don't mean a network firewall
where you have a whitelist and you're
looking and software for example the
table by P dress is your yearly for what
I mean is that these firewalls are like
a mapping and this mapping is done in
registers and when you can map a
peripheral to a core so in this example
we have multiple cores the firewall
guarantees that if another core tries to
access that peripheral over the bus that
access is simply denied it's just it's
just a no op so being on the program the
spire walls and have them forced in
silicon and having a denied
all strategy means that you're guarding
against cross-court axe and cross core
volunteers
such a place to every service in the
system Ram Network flash and every
single peripheral flows through this
mapping in silicon this means you know
if you're on one of the cores and the
hacker attacks it and they've access to
UART and they want to hop over and
access a spy or access some of the SRAM
attached to the a7 it's simply not
possible now one of the interesting
properties here is that we talked about
a lot of these silicon defenses as
sticky what does that mean it means once
you program this mapping it cannot be
reset so even if the until the entire
chip goes through its reset process so
even if the code that programs the
firewall is exploited or has a
privileged escalation an attacker cannot
reset the firewall and reprogram it for
access to resources didn't originally
have having that you can leave as a
right once setting finally have an MCU
we have a traditional MCU and on these
cross rim see use it's where you do
real-time computation Kirill Tim XS is
basically bare-metal execution with a
traditional art sauce because that
compartmentalization in silicon we
prevent that software from basically
running amok other than the sandbox we
provided it so basically you can run
whatever you want there a lot of
manufacturers have their existing art us
that they want to run and we're they're
free to deploy it and run it we just
treat it like an application so we have
a lot of silicon partners that have made
announcements and supporting these chips
where are the first chips from idiot X
called the MT 36:20 it's available in
market now we're gonna see a lot more
chips coming to market in this space
over the next couple of years so let's
talk a little bit about the operating
system at the bottom we're running an
ARM processor running in trust owns and
Trust in Portland's insecure world we
have a security monitor that protects
access to resources all those silicon
countermeasures I talked about are all
programmed from a secure world they
can't be set from normal world
yeah we're custom linux kernel these on
ship calling cloud services for
authentication and connectivity and then
you have our application called
containers or sand boxes don't think
about a docker container you know in the
space we're talking about with a couple
Meg's of RAM a typical application is
maybe 80 kilobytes so we're talking
about a sandbox that's reduce the
surface area for execution so a little
more detail here so as you mentioned
earlier this curated user environment
there's no passwords no shell nor user
accounts basically application has own
manifest format the manifest is part of
the application package that's signed by
Microsoft we can parse that manifest
German exact resource it's the
applications requesting and guarantee
that all those resources are accessed of
course we use things like TLS for to
implement mutual efficacious those are
run inside the inside the operating
system in normal world where Linux
kernel has its own limit security module
that protects resource acquisition and
manages access to pluton services like
our random number generator and the
security monitor in addition to granting
access to hard resources by programming
all those silicon countermeasures also
implements technologies like eraser
coding to guarantee against runtime
corruption on flash so that's the OS
jump to the security service what are we
getting out the security service how do
we actually broke her trust well it we
use the security service to connect all
our devices and we send our failure
reporting through it so we can do
analytics and look for attacks out in
the wild we all see the security service
to push updates back down to devices and
I just her device updates can't be
turned off it's part of the agreement
that device manufactures accept that
we're always allowed to take an update
and push it out to device so what are we
getting from a SATA station so right at
the station allows you to check not only
the devices running genuine software but
it's ring up-to-date software so the way
we're leveraging attestation is that an
opportunity advices issued a very
short-lived search so think about assert
that allele is a day that certain thing
can be presented to any service from the
AWS or asher and if you can verify the
search chain effectively Microsoft is
vouching for the health of the device
for the moment time would add to
station' was completed if it's device is
out of date it doesn't get the cert
actually get something called a
quarantine cert that can only be used
next to our update service and we can
force that update to occur so this
allows us to prevent basically Alyssa
take these security services scale out
beyond microsoft services by using a
certificate which is a really common
format that can be understood in person
so courses Visual Studio for development
you might be surprised at a lot of times
the MCU space modern development tools
aren't very common so bringing a Visual
Studio to market I think there's a demo
I think tomorrow you guys can play with
the device and see how easy this is
taking the development kit can accept
Azure and scene telemetry takes about
you know ten minutes so so I'm running
out of time so we kind of conclude the
other thing I want to talk about we
might not normally talk about in this
space is you know we talk a lot about
subscriptions right now description is a
big way a lot of companies do business
we didn't want to do that when it came
to securing devices we didn't want you
to have to think month-to-month is this
device worth subscribing is securing or
not so when the chip is sold it comes
with a license the license guarantees
the security services gonna run
basically for ten years we guarantee
updates all management service the
device so that cost I think is I think
we're the public price we've announced
is less than ten dollars for ten years
so including the chip so we're hoping to
basically take some of this the secure
service and push it down market into the
MCU space with all the features were
talking about in plutonomy the other
thing is that's open so we're a
licensing the plutons subsystem for free
to any silicon manufacturer that wants
to implement a sphere chip we are of
course it's the Linux kernel GPL so
that's open available for people to
contribute to and it works with any
cloud so because the way the security
service works if you're hosting all of
your service and WS or Google or Azure
you can leverage the security service
for the security the device and or and
and work with any service that's out
there so that is the 10,000 foot view
about your sphere and I'm happy to take
any questions
you mentioned thanks for the talk you
mentioned the issue of it seems like
updates are critical and there seems to
be a tension between what you allow to
be updated and what may not be updated
you mentioned the firewall can't be
updated and yet other things can be
updated obviously if the firewall has a
vulnerability in it you'd want to update
it could you say a little bit about how
you result what's the philosophy and
what how you resolve the tension to
ensure that updates can't be abused and
yet they will occur when needed yeah
great question
anything anything basically anything in
software can be updated so the real
tension is what are we pushing - what
are we pushing the silicon and are the
is the functionality pushing the silicon
either simple enough they would have
confident that's correct so a bug in the
in the firewall in silicon would would
be not obtainable right that would be a
core vulnerability in the chip that
would effectively have to recall the
chips to replace them or we try to use
things like formal era fication so
portions of pluton has been have been
formally verified to ensure that for
example the cryptographic algorithms are
correct if it's in software we're going
to update it we ship updates out to it
so we try to draw that line which is
what we put into silicon and what we
keep the software determine with
available but it's tough because if you
ship a buggins you know putting these
cryptographic algorithms in silicon it
means they're already more secure but it
also means if there was a bug you're
gonna have to actually go out and
replace the chip nope yes my name is
Daniel sounds like this may incorporate
the use of like a mini hardware security
module and if so has it been submitted
for NIST validation and if so what
that's level are we shooting for for it
great I don't have all the details so
we've internally we're fips-compliant
and I think the team working up because
I didn't mention this pluton comes from
a few decades of experience with
Microsoft Hardware so this is internal
silicon isn't
its internal silicon has been defending
other products and protecting other
products in your ecosystem that we've
kind of simplified a bit and brought
down into the MCU space so we've gone
through internally Fitz compliance we
have not gone through formal v
certification but we could ask about
that a lot and I think that's gonna be
the next step
yeah I guess that forgot this one thing
I forgot to mention is that you
mentioned HSM Putin just generated some
key pairs internally in silicon as well
so we have you know there's some of
these chips where you blow fuses and
take keys you do them in HSM you send
them over wire we even feel like that's
that's insecure so the keys are never
accessed by software even the most
trusted piece of saw from the device can
never see the private key that's all
generated in silicon and blowing fuses
good question thank you hi Subin Mohan
from UIUC you talked about I mean you
know motivation for this originally you
talk about MC use right so is there any
kind of are there any kind of real-time
properties that can be guaranteed or or
real-time priorities in the Linux OS
that you're designed for this or can we
add it in later I think you could you
could look at adding soft real-time but
it's one of the reasons why we have that
extra m4 core that M core that was on
that on that diagram that's kind of
firewalled off is that if you basically
the MCOR bare middle execution so you
can load in our toss your toss some
other our toss on there and have full
control over the core Microsoft doesn't
you fear with it there's no today so if
you wanted you needed to do microsecond
timing or something like that you could
do it there so Linux is you know so
because of all the connectivity
operations and update other pieces that
go on in the Linux kernel it's not
really the placing when you built an
execution
the MCOR them cord is mmmyou it has an
MP u so it's eight but it's given us
some segments in which to execute and
then within that space it's pretty do
whatever once so it's free to take that
piece of RAM that it's given and treated
however it likes the questions all right
great thanks is there other questions on
please reach out to me at let me talk
about it thank you well I'm Adam chapala
and I'm going to be talking about some
of our experiences applying formal
methods to systems and some ideas for
now that formal methods are relatively
practical for this kind of stuff what
does that mean about how we should
change the way that we design our
systems and take advantage of some of
the the structuring principles that
formal methods allow so let me start out
by talking about maybe the standard
story people have in their heads about
how we're going to use formal methods
where we're building systems we we
somehow gather requirements for what
those systems to do we have designs and
then we write some code and we iterate
through applying Quality Assurance
methods like testing and debugging and
code review and we do that enough and we
become sufficiently confident that we
can release something and let people use
it and not be be too worried about
serious security problems so the
standard story of formal methods is that
we have it as an alternative kind of
quality control that we apply without
really changing the parts of the
implementation approach that would
normally be used but we're going to do
some extra work to prove that the system
really does what it's supposed to do and
in particular especially for my own work
what I'm talking about here is
mechanized end-to-end proofs of
functional correctness so let me take a
few slides to briefly summarize what I
mean by those words and then I'll get
into some more applications of the
approach so when I say mechanized proofs
I mean we use a theorem provers software
package called a proof assistant the
when my group uses is called Cooke and
what this means is you can take the
actual source code of your real system
and write a formal specification for it
as source code in another language and
finally write a proof as source code and
yet
language that establishes that your
system really meets the specification
we're gonna feed all these three into
the proof checking software package and
it will automatically validate that the
the proof actually establishes the
specification that you have in mind and
when I talk about functional correctness
I mean we're not just going to for
instance prove that the system never
crashes we're going to write down a
rather specific concept of correctness
for instance if all the inputs up to
this point where the following then the
output had better be this and finally
when I talk about end-to-end proofs I
mean we have halfway realistic systems
that are naturally broken up into layers
and the layers all have their own
specifications and we can prove each
layer individually but then we take the
time to plug all these results together
and get a an end-to-end guarantee that
only needs to talk about sort of a top
and bottom api's of a stack like this
and many of the internal details drop
out of the trusted computing base so
these kinds of ideas can influence the
ways that we we address classic
trade-offs and system design like the
one between performance and
maintainability where usually we worried
that as we improve the performance of a
system that the code gets harder to
understand but it's it's it's worth it
given the only use that we expect our
systems to see so one question that we
might have is is this pattern
fundamental where today we expect
building a realistic high performance
system involves writing a lot of
intricate low-level code where it's very
easy to make mistakes that jeopardize
the the correctness or the security of a
system so let me try to convince you
that we can use formal methods to
actually change this assumption for
building realistic systems and I'll do
that with a to start out with a concrete
example that we've already explored at
MIT so one area which was mentioned as
just part of the story in the last talk
is cryptographic primitives and a
particular elliptic curve cryptography
is one of the most widely used
approaches for instance for initial
an HTTP connection and here's some C
code written by one of the experts on
this kind of stuff for the elliptic
curve that is generally viewed as the
easiest one to implement efficiently and
I think this is code for taking a big
number that's too big to fit in one
register of hardware and squaring it
modulo some large prime number and it is
moderately intricate and it's repetitive
enough that if you try to audit this you
might easily roll yourself into a false
sense of security and believe everything
looks okay and this is just one part of
a larger piece of code which
historically this kind of thing has all
been written by hands but it'll be nice
to know this code is correct and there
are a few competing approaches to doing
that one of them is to find a student or
an intern who's willing to read through
all these lines of code and write lots
of invariants and convince an SMT solver
that this is correct and that's a
wonderful time honored technique that I
won't try to trash talk too much but
what we can do instead is wonder just do
we really need to write code like this
to get high performance crypto maybe
it's an opportunity to notice building
formal proofs of things is hard it
pushes us towards simplifying system
implementations which is an
independently useful thing maybe there's
a better way to write this where we'll
we'll get a proof and we won't have to
look at code like this so just to
motivate a little bit more about why
this is an interesting domain oh it is
the standard advice is don't write your
own crypto code and probably most
developers try to follow this advice
most of the time we have a relatively
small number of libraries that that
implement the most important
cryptographic routines but there's a
moderate moderately large space out
there of different cryptographic
algorithms that matter and then there
are parameters for those algorithms one
important example is a large prime
number that you use as the modulus for
arithmetic and then there's a small to
medium ish set of interestingly
different hardware architectures that we
want to run this code on when I was
first learning about this area I was
really surprised to hear that for every
element of this three-way cross-product
the state of practice is to rewrite all
the code from scratch
in assembly to get the best performance
so there there really isn't there hadn't
been very good abstraction in the way
that this kind of code is developed and
maintained and that means there are a
lot of opportunities for making mistakes
where we get incorrect cryptographic
primitives that can can wreck your
security guarantees so we wanted to go
at this in the so-called correct by
construction way it'll be sort of a way
of writing the code so at every point
all the code you have is guaranteed to
be computing the correct answer and
there's a long history of this kind of
formal reasoning in cryptography where
we typically start with a property like
I have a digital signature scheme
no one can forge signatures if they
don't know the right secrets and then we
can apply the idea of protocol
verification to show that some
mathematical algorithm provides that
guarantee subject to standard
assumptions and then we could do for
instance implementations synthesis to
come up with low level fast code that
provably implements that algorithm I
think the next talk in this session will
talk about the other direction
implementation verification where you
have the code already and then you're
going to prove that it influenced the
algorithm but let me talk about the
downward direction the way I've drawn
this here implementation and synthesis
is what I'll be focusing on in this
project so to give an idea of how we can
in a principled way derive the code that
we want to run instead of just starting
with a pile of C code or assembly we'll
start out with mathematical algorithms
which in this domain of elliptic curves
are all about two-dimensional geometry
and then typically one substitutes in a
less obvious but more efficient
implementation of points which sort of
counter intuitively adds more
coordinates to make things faster
because we can run fewer expensive
instructions when we rearrange things
this way and so this first step is just
a classic data structure correctness
proof in the sense of abstract data
types and abstraction relations and all
that stuff so we break down in that
reaction relation between these two
versions and prove that it's respected
by the code then we have to implement
the individual coordinates of these
points which are all by themselves
pretty hard to get to run quickly
because every coordinate is way too
large to fit in the red
is that that a commodity hardware it
provides so we have to think about
division of numbers into multiple digits
and so we we prove kind of big num
arithmetic in in this style to connect
that part and then finally an aspect
that all I don't have time to talk about
in too much detail we have a verified
compiler at the end that takes the
functional programs that are coming out
of this process that work with infinite
precision integers and infers bit widths
for all temporary variables and does
other compiler optimization things and
then out pops sort of idiomatic C code
with particular types for all the
variables that are being used the
important thing is each of those arrows
on the right side is carrying a proof
and they're all snapped together in a
common framework so we get that the
low-level code is truly implementing the
the mathematical algorithm that we
started with and this whole pipeline
runs automatically it's it's not a new
manual effort to consider a new space I
showed you three clouds when you change
up one of the second two clouds this is
automatic when you've a new algorithm
that's new work so our project is called
Fiat cryptography it takes place within
the context of a larger multi University
project called science of deep
specifications and which paid for this
lovely logo which is a reference to the
Spy vs spy comic for anyone who familiar
with those and I've listed down here my
students who've worked on this project
oh this is basically a platform for
correct by construction generation of
elliptic curve cryptography
implementations and we hope later other
kinds of cryptography so what we
basically do is we're going to think
about the arithmetic that goes into
these algorithms at a high level we're
gonna do some functional programming of
the kind you might even assign in a
freshman programming class we're going
to represent big numbers as lists of
pairs of numbers every pair has a
compile-time part in a runtime part the
compile-time part is the weight of that
digit it's like how many bits to shift
it by and the runtime part is the actual
digital value we're not going to be very
specific about which weights are allowed
whether we can have duplicate weights or
anything like that we just have lists
and pairs of numbers and we can write
down implementations of classic
operations like multiplication but that
one works by just taking all the cross
products of the elements of two lists
and we can just write that as a
functional program that uses famous
higher-order functions like flat map and
map and it's a very small amount of code
and we can write lemmas that we proved
in the cochlear improver that that shows
that this multiplication operation is
related to the normal multiplication
operator in the appropriate way and we
can take ingredients like that and put
them together into higher-level
operations so this is one that is going
to take in two big numbers a and B that
follow a particular digit representation
with n digits in this case this function
is actually generic in the number n
using polymorphism and then we convert
each of those fixed representations into
our flexible internal representation we
do the multiplication we run a mod
operation which is by convention called
reduce here and then we convert back out
of the flexible representation into the
fixed Network format so this is a really
nice from a software engineering
standpoint this code is so much easier
to understand then the the C code that I
showed before but if we just say take
this and treat it like Oh camel code or
Haskell code and compile it in the
normal way it's like a hundred or more
times slower than that that C code that
I showed so we need to do something
about that and the approach we're going
to take is a classic idea in compilers
called partial evaluation so we have for
instance our multiply operation
it's parameterised on the static part
information on the digit representation
of numbers which could be different for
different elliptic curves and then we
have the actual digit values so first
we'll specialize this function to a
particular set of digit bit widths now
all it takes in or the digits themselves
and then we will reduce and simplify
algebraically that program until all the
overhead of the generousity is gone and
we have a lean specialized multiply
routine and then we'll actually speed
this into the verified compiler I talked
about which will and ferb it widths and
do it the other things you need to get C
code from the functional programming
view
we started with so how does this
actually pay off for a performance so we
we oh I should mention each of these
arrows here is is a built in operation
of our chosen theorem prove a so
this is all very straightforward to do
specialization is just partially
applying a curried function to some of
its arguments and the reduced stage is
just calling a built-in reducer that is
one of the standard building blocks of
proof of program correctness so that's a
very natural process so we get out C
code that looks a lot like the the code
I showed at the beginning at least at
the abstract syntax level it's not as
nice to read directly and the concrete
characters that we output and if we
compare performance on curve two five
five one nine which is the for instance
Google wants to talk this this curve to
you if you try to connect to to their
their main website if your browser
supports it it'll it'll use this one and
here's some examples of how many CPU
cycles are needed for one of the top
level elliptic curve operations I forget
which one and you can see there's our
code up at the top there we generate
both 64-bit and 32-bit versions so these
benchmark results are on a 64-bit
machine so the 32-bit results aren't
super interesting for performance and
we're very close to the best-known
assembly code for for this the curve and
in fact we are now as far as I know
generating the fastest known C code for
essentially every elliptic curve with
one automatic pipeline that that
generates proofs and to demonstrate that
we scraped information on elliptic
curves online and tried to compute the
set of all the prime numbers that anyone
associates with this field so we can
automatically generate implementations
for from modular arithmetic for all
those Prime's and we did it for both a
64-bit desktop machine with an x86
processor and a 32-bit arm machine which
is actually an Android phone and we
compare against the the previous highest
performance generic implementation of
this stuff which is the new multi
precision library which has multiple
variants one of which actually is
appropriate for secure
crypto style applications where you
don't leak information about inputs to
your arithmetic through timing but we
also compared against a version that
does leak information through timing
which which should only make it harder
for us to show performance improvement
and and still over the space of all
these these primes that we spider it off
the internet we we're seeing typically a
a performance improvement in the range
of 2 X 2 to 10 X and we have formal
proofs of all these implementations
which the new multi precision library
doesn't have and finally we managed to
convince the the team at Google that
manages the boring is to sell library
which is a it started out as a heavily
inspired by the open SSL library but as
they have urged a lot since then to
adopt our approach to replace their
grungy handwritten code for elliptic
curve arithmetic so the two most
commonly used Lifta curves are 2 5 5 1 9
and P 256 and our code is in there now
for both of those with distinct 64-bit
and 32-bit versions and the student
doing an internship as we speak at
Google who will hopefully have P 384 the
the third most frequently used Lifta
curve done in the next month or so and
so this library is used in Chrome it's
used in Android it's used on Google
servers and so now about half of all
HTTP connections from browsers use our
formally generated implementations of
the curve operations so I started out
posing this question do we really need
to spend our time writing intricate
low-level code to get performance in the
systems that we're building and we're
talking about formal methods it's
probably not a surprise that we can to
some extent get rid of that bug prone
quality even if we keep writing the same
kinds of code as before but hopefully
I've also showed how we can remove the
need to write low-level code and do more
of our thinking in a nice higher-level
way with more of the nice software
engineering properties that we prefer to
have here's a related question whenever
we add new abstractions to a system we
worried that there will be some
it's cost for those abstractions even if
it makes the system nicer to think about
if we if we do adopt these kinds of
event and formal methods there there
could be ways to to lower the costs of
adding abstraction to a system that we
might not think about if we have to
stick to traditional implementations so
let me talk about one way to think about
how we could apply this this idea in
general I think that the last talk was
was a great example of a classic
approach to security and isolation in a
system by imposing various runtime
mechanisms to to contain compartments
and limit what could happen to different
parts of a system I think of a lot of
different examples from processors to
operating systems to database systems as
having as their missions in life are to
provide a kind of high-level imaginary
view of how a bunch of parts of a system
run and share resources where we can
imagine there are these impenetrable
walls between the different some parts
of a world like this every one of the
parts get gets to be written in a nice
high-level language it uses nice api's
we can pretend there are dedicated
processing resources dedicated storage
and so on for each one of these these
blocks and many traditional deployed
systems today literally realize this
picture in the way hardware and software
are set up but in general what we're
trying to do here is come up with a real
optimized system that in some sense can
be having a dream and imagining it lives
in that nice world but there's a lot
more resource sharing to improve
performance in various ways we might
call this top view of things a virtual
machine and maybe a kind of older sense
of the phrase which is just a nice
abstract view of an executing system
that doesn't have to get into the
details of how we we do resource sharing
or we could just call it a specification
which is already a common idea in formal
methods and and think about how we can
use compile time reasoning to show that
a system truly implements this
abstraction without leaving any runtime
residue of the approach that forces us
to keep paying a performance cost
each time we use the mechanisms that we
develop so one direction that I'm
interested in in pushing on in the near
future is to try to take this all the
way and move all of our reasoning about
isolation to to compile time and get
good performance get good abstractions
without having to make compromises there
so the the idea is I I wanted to think
of a stack of systems components as
essentially in a platform for efficient
execution of simple functional programs
where we build up abstraction x' that
that successively show how to implement
the high level features that we're
relying on I want this the starting
specifications we work with and be so
simple that we can more or less just
have a few people read them and we'll
catch the major issues the code will be
so short that's feasible I want to try
applying a proof carrying code approach
where we we just say if you want to run
your code on my system you need to give
me a proof of full functional
correctness or I'm not going to accept
it and I think this is getting to be
feasible for both software and digital
hardware and this should be doable in an
end-to-end way where we're going to take
all the proofs that we require be
provided for all the components
installed on the system
and snap them all together so that we
get a very small TCB that contains just
our proof checker as well as the
semantics of sort of the top and bottom
level api's of the system where the
bottom is ideally a hardware description
language and that the top is just the
nice high-level functional version of
our applications and the system api view
that they see and if we do this right
each of those top and bottom what levels
should be on the order of a thousand
lines of code and very doable to saud it
and catch major issues in and we should
be able to by using this proof approach
avoid all runtime isolation mechanisms
and and push all of our reasoning about
that it's a proofs so here's an example
of a stack of pieces that that could
head in that direction so I want to
start with the top level view of the
system is nice functional programs that
we could view as the specification and
they would use design patterns like
object capabilities so that
just by construction we achieve proper
least privilege and we control the
information flow graph of within parts
of a system we achieve access control
just using pointers in a in a type safe
language and then we can rely on a
compiler that's going to produce c-lite
code from that point that does things
like static analysis to infer object
lifetimes to insert manual memory
management code so we won't need
anything like a garbage collector then
we are systems level programming
language wouldn't need to have a type
system because if we're already
committing to proving everything
functionally correct then a type system
is just an approximation of functional
correctness so we can leave that out and
expose a view of memory as an array of
bytes directly but with structured
control flow and functions and other
good stuff like that on top of it the
compiler for that language will do
things like worst-case running time
analysis tell us how long a function
might take to run this might depend on
some annotations the programmer needs to
provide and maybe prove some things
about but then once we've done that we
can output machine code which is
prepared to run on machines in the the
microcontroller class that was one of
the one of the parts of the diagram the
last talk showed where we don't have
virtual memory or other address space
protection we don't we don't have have
interrupts we just have a machine that
knows how to run machine code functions
when you ask it to and so then what does
the processor do it keeps receiving IO
events from the world and for each one
it knows which function to call in the
pile of machine code that we've produced
and that function just runs to the end
and decides what to do next including
signalling any any response output
events that should happen and it's safe
to avoid using interrupts or anything
like that here because we did worst case
execution time analysis and all the code
and it we don't depend on virtual memory
to isolate the different parts of the
system because that was all present in
the original functional code through
object capability system and other such
patterns and and preserved through
semantics guarantees about all the
levels bringing us down to this point
one thing that's kind of hard about a
good worst case execution time analysis
of realistic
code is predicting the cost of memory
operations given complex cash systems so
one other idea that we're thinking about
is taking the high-level view we have of
code to preserve down through this whole
stack proved accurate characterizations
of which objects in memory each each
function is going to need so that the
memory system and the cache coherence
protocol can move into place in the
cache at whichever processor gets picked
to run a function guaranteed all the
objects it's going to need so that when
we actually run the code we know exactly
how long it's going to take or we can
least get a much more accurate bound
than before so that's the idea there and
to summarize I think it's worth
exploring how some of the challenges
that we're used to seeing is fundamental
in the design of systems software can
can really be rearranged by by
committing to functional correctness
proofs for all parts of a system and
this technology has really advanced a
lot I think in the next 10 years or so
this will this will be be mainstream and
I think it's interesting to consider
what domains there are out there where
if we wanted to reimplementation scratch
that this would be pretty feasible and I
think there are more cases of that then
then we'd think from the usual
conversations about this sort of stuff
Thanks
[Applause]
questions
it's very impressive could you say a bit
about how you would have caught the
problems of interference between
speculative execution and cashing in
this picture and more generally our
processor abstractions have the property
that there are a lot of details we don't
know about and in a sense abstractions
are bad for security because they hide
from the implementer properties that the
attacker takes advantage of so how does
that fit into this picture that strongly
based on abstractions let me start with
the the second question or maybe try to
clarify the intent of it if you're
talking about abstraction through closed
Hardware designs from from manufacturers
out there today then that doesn't fit so
well into our picture but if you think
about open source hardware designs like
are coming up in the context of the the
RISC 5 instruction set then that that
fits completely well it's into this this
picture and we're doing some work in
that area ourselves where you can assign
a semantics to the hardware description
language that includes timing of all
interactions with the outside world and
you can formulate what it means for
timing to be independent of secret
inputs coming in on certain wires and
then if you manage to prove that theorem
then you really have avoided inspector
and meltdown kind of attacks but there
is a challenge there that I think the
architecture community doesn't quite
know yet what the actual changes to the
workings of processors are to avoid
those issues while keeping performance
so we'll just try to be ready with
general proof tools for whenever those
mechanisms are known
I've got a question so here related to
timing how much when when people write
these functional correctness
specifications how much do you expect
people to say about timing like if they
send if they say I'm going to say send
five messages to somebody do they have
to say exactly when they're gonna send
those messages so they don't leak any
any bits through the timing of the
messages right so we one approach is to
require high-level functional
specifications that for each operation
you can run the functional program needs
to compute the write the running time
that it expects to have in the real
world and that can be kind of an opaque
function you don't know what it is but
you know it's well defined in the
terminus stick so it's hard to see how
to avoid heading in that direction to
really avoid all the information leaks
but this is pretty speculative right now
Thanks one question is about observing
side channels other than timing so for
example power side channels or radio
emissions how what aspects of your work
do you think translate well from timing
analysis to other analysis and what
aspects John yeah so those other side
channels I really not very well informed
about but if someone who was could come
up with some security condition that
applies to RTL designs then we could
probably incorporate that in this
framework
I'm not informed enough to know what
that might that kind of condition might
look like so as you were presenting the
crypto work the voice in my back of my
head was saying oh yes but crypto code
has a nice clean functional spec and
it's all self-contained doesn't have to
deal with memory models and interrupts
and all these things and then we get to
the end of your talk and it seems like
your answer to that problem is we'll
make it go away right that's a great
clean slate design but you have any
thoughts about how we get from here to
there incrementally because that sounds
like a hard change to make we the crypto
stuff is easy to deploy because it plugs
into the existing system and it you know
observably makes it better but I don't
see how you could you could
incrementally deploy something like this
have you thought about that so I think
I'm not suggesting incremental
deployment in that sense but just
building some cool boxes of the kind we
heard about in the last talk using this
framework which then talked to the rest
of the world through standard protocols
and interfaces any other questions
it's Chris so talk about project Everest
which is a joint effort among several
Microsoft labs as well as in RIA and
Carnegie Mellon and it's it's a project
that we've had going for a couple of
years now that's aiming to build and
deploy verified components in the HTTP
ecosystem so I think you know what HTTPS
is even if you don't you use it I'm
pretty sure every day essentially when
you connect on the web to any secure
website whether it's a bank or your your
email you negotiated a a secure channel
using a protocol a cryptographic
protocol that that's that underlies
issue that underlies HTTPS so on the
surface the the most common usages
through this this this web web protocol
but within HTTPS is actually quite a
complex ecosystem there's at the heart
of it is a is a protocol called TLS
transport layer security beneath which
lies several crypto algorithms and
alongside it are things like the public
key infrastructure ultimately talking to
the network through a TCP there above it
are clients and servers that incorporate
this the suite of protocols the the
trouble with this with HTTPS is that
although you know you should still use
it and it's significantly better than
not using any protection at all
it's every the protocols in in this
space and the algorithms in the space
have been hit by attacks and
corresponding fixes for 20 years or more
and maybe the the one that's got the
most attention is is this heartbleed bug
which in a way is a very boring bug
heartbleed was essentially exploiting a
a buffer over on a memory safety
vulnerability to compromised TLS
implementations of TLS but there have
been other kinds of
two that have that are independent of
implementations they've been designed
flaws in in the protocols and all the
mainstream implementations have been
subject to to these flaws open SSL is
the the most widely used implementation
but Microsoft's s channel is also very
widely used
there's NSS from Mozilla there are
others boring SSL things that have
fought from open SSL all of them have
been attacked and get repeatedly patched
so in 2016 we started a project that had
a five-year scope so we're about halfway
through it and we had a few goals our
first goal was to build a verified
implementation of the components in in
HTTPS and our goal is to actually build
these components in a form where they
are low-level and are efficient enough
to be deployed as is inside the existing
software ecosystem now in doing so we
are building and improving verification
tools that have been developed at MSR f
star is a programming language that it's
a proof assistant in the spirit of
something like that that Adam
mentioned but using an automated theorem
prover called z3 that that's also been
developed at Microsoft so in in in
pursuing project Everest and building
these verified components we also aim to
produce more trustworthy trustworthy
usable verification tools and to grow
expertise in building this kind of
verified software at this kind of scale
and and finally we we strongly believe
that this kind of security work has to
be done in the open so everything that
we do is is open-source including the
the tools estar is open source and and
all that verified software that we do
we're a large team of people who work on
this at several MSR labs so
Redmond Cambridge and India several of
whom are in the room there's Chris and
Tina and Jonathan at least that I see
who work on Everest so feel free to you
know come find us and ask us questions
about this
there's aside from the MS our labs we
have collaborators at collaborators at
inria in Paris who we work with there's
an MSR in Rio Joint Center at Paris and
we work with them through this
arrangement and we have collaborators at
CMU in and and at the University of
Edinburgh and a long list of interns
visitors and so on and we're very open
to collaboration so if you're interested
in this kind of stuff and would like to
work with us get in touch and so here's
here's where we are at sort of two and a
half years we've we have verified
implementations of most of the the key
cipher suites that are used in in in TLS
we've for the moment not look so much at
the public key infrastructure but have
instead been looking at a protocol
called quick which is a new development
in this in this ecosystem so quick is a
new networking protocol that has been is
undergoing a standardization process at
the IETF driven initially by Google and
it's trying to do
TLS over UDP in in a you know kind of a
new clean slate redesign so we have we
have deployments of our verified code in
test deployments in three clients the
edge browser the curl
library that lets you do command line
curl is actually used in many many tools
but it's one of its uses is user is just
fetching pages from fetching web content
nginx is a open source web server and we
have a test deployment in there but
aside from these test deployments there
are two we have two main production
scale deployments so Windows is
developing a an implementation of quick
kaldwin quick and win quick uses TLS and
a versus TLS runs in in win quick and is
now part of the windows development
builds we also being open source our
code runs also outside Microsoft so
Mozilla's NSS library which is used in
Firefox and another Mozilla tools
runs Everest scripture specifically the
decryption algorithms not yet the
protocol stack so so when we're talking
about verification that you know there's
there's always a question of like well
what do you actually verify and as a
baseline for all this kind of work you
verify safety so without memory safety
you can't really get very far in proving
anything further that's the baseline a
level of abstraction that that you need
to prove so we prove safety for all our
code and then depending on the component
that that we're verifying we pick
properties that we think are the most
suitable for those components so usually
this means at least functional
correctness but for certain components
we will also prove things like
cryptographic security meaning that we
bound the probability that an attacker
can break a certain crypto construction
despite despite all our proofs you may
ask you know will Everest be perfectly
secure and the answer to this is no all
this kind of verification work is based
on a set of assumptions both with
respect to the specifications that you
write so you know if you're skeptical
about Everest or any verification
project for that matter you need to you
need to study the specifications that
are actually proven about the code and
convince yourself that the specs
actually mean what you think they mean
specs are written with respect to a
model and our models try to be detailed
and cover all classes of known attacks
but there may be new classes of attacks
that we are not aware of that
may may make our models inadequate also
our verification tool chain places trust
in a number of components including F
star the theory theorem provers that we
use on on C compilers and so on and
those are part of our trusted computing
base despite these limitations the the
general methodology of using
computer-aided verification has some
clear advantages verification is
automated it may take several hours but
you make a change and you want to know
if your change was breaking a system
invariant well the system is the
verification system is going to tell you
as part of a continuous integration
system it's the way in which you can get
a proof to work at this scale is by
breaking it up into components and so
verification is modular and
compositional meaning that you can take
a component say a particular crypto
construction that we use inside TLS and
also use it in some other component
which is for instance our usage of TLS
and quic is a great example of this
TLS was intended for use initially over
TCP but the same crypto protocol can
also be used in a different setting like
quick write so the programming and
verification tools that we use our is a
at the source level is a programming
language called called F star F star
makes use of xiii-2 to prove
verification conditions that arise from
as you try to write your program so
after you write your f star program and
verify it you can compile it either to
oh camel or in a tool that we've
developed as part of Everest you can
extract you have star code to C and then
compile it using a C compiler and Link
it with the rest of your system so let
me do a small demo of this so that big
enough in the back ish okay
so so this is what this is f star
running in emacs and and and that's our
program its syntax superficially looks a
bit like functional languages like Oh
camel or F sharp but within this this
framework you can encode other dsls so
I'm showing you here a DSL that we have
in F star for writing see like programs
and this demo is a very simple example
that's showing how you may copy the
contents of one or a to another copy
from the source array to the destory and
the the the way in which you do this
copy is really simple it's a it's a
recursive function that assigns the
current byte of source to test and then
recursos on increasing the counter by
one now when you try to write such a
program you're forced in F star to prove
various basic properties about it so you
see these comments that I have here that
say that at various points in this code
F star will force you to prove temporal
safety for instance meaning that you
cannot access a a a memory location
unless you prove that the memory
location is currently live or when you
do it
integer operation you need to prove that
there's no integer overflow so having
written this code you can ask that star
to check it and it'll say in this case
says yes but if I forget a precondition
for instance I try to use the source
array without knowing that the source
array is is life and I ask at start of
arif I it it will complain
pointing at a location here that says
well at that index this says live it you
couldn't prove that the buffer that you
were accessing was live at that point so
this first attempt here is just proving
that copy is safe to run it doesn't
prove anything about what copy actually
accomplishes so this bit of the spec
here is an insurance clause which says
at the end of running this code there's
something that you can assume is true
about the state of the program and in
this case the insurance Clause is just
true so you don't get anything
you don't get any functional correctness
property out of this version of copy but
here's another version of copy where
it's the same code as I showed you
before but it's now augmented with a
spec that tells you that after you run
copy in the final memory h1 that results
after running this program the source
and the destination buffers are equal
which is what you what you might expect
from from doing copy so so I've star
like such agrees agrees with this
specification so having done this you
can then having verified your program
you can you can compile your program to
to see and here I did this just a little
while ago so this is an extraction of
the previous program to see and notice
that when you extract to see you just
get C code that you would expect with
all the specifications erased and with
no remaining runtime checks or anything
all the verification is static so the
style of verification generally imposes
no additional runtime performance
overhead right so so that's a sub
language that I showed you in F star for
extract for programming at the C level
of abstraction but to get performant
code especially in some of these scripts
of applications you need to go beyond C
and so we have another DSL called veil
which is a a a a DSL embedded in F star
for programming at the at the assembly
level building verified assembly
programs so with these tools we aim to
build TLS and protocols like it and for
TLS the the main security goal that
you're after is to is to show that TLS
establishes the secure channel
meaning that you get a channel between
the endpoints that is authentic meaning
that an adversary cannot inject forth
data into the stream and it's
confidential
meaning that anniversary cannot
distinguish between the communication of
random bytes and a secret on the stream
the TLS protocol has through the year
has been
it's design has been vulnerable in many
ways but TLS 1.3 is it is a new version
the latest version of the protocol that
is now a a ITF proposed standard in the
process of us verifying TLS 1.3 we
discovered many potential protocol flaws
in earlier versions of the design and
proposed I think we have six proposals
in the in the in the proposed standard
from that I've been incorporated in the
proposed standard that that arose as a
result of us doing our our verification
work and the IETF has generally been I
think quite receptive to this at least
in in the TLS committee has been
receptive to this kind of formal work as
well the standard for instance sites
both ours as well as several other
formal models of of TLS as a validation
of the design of the protocol so the way
in which we model cryptographic security
is and prove it is is in the following
manner so you have a concrete
implementation of TLS that's using a
crypto provider a crypto library that's
implementing the actual algorithms and
you have a an application program or
which may also represent the adversary
interacting with TLS and what we do is
our general proof methodology is to show
that this concrete version of TLS is
indistinguishable from an ideal version
of TLS about which we can prove that it
actually implements a secure Channel and
the way we do that is by verifying the
crypto library and then making use of a
cryptographic hypothesis to say to show
that clients of this library are these
two clients of this library are
indistinguishable except for a ace a
security parameter probability
determined by a security parameter
having done that we can then approve the
ideal version of TLS information
theoretically secure with no more
cryptography in the picture
and with with that step of the proof
complete you can then show that it that
an attacker cannot distinguish between
concrete CLS and ideal TLS except also
for some probability epsilon so that's
our general proof methodology at the top
level in order to apply this this
methodology there's there are various
proof steps that become necessary along
the way so here's the structure of one
simple workflow through TLS so TLS is a
socket like API you connect you create
it try to create a secure socket that
triggers the the run of a TLS handshake
that's going to negotiate secrets
between negotiate keys between the two
endpoints which then requires actually
you know sending some plaintext bytes
out on the wire that's which which will
then get the TLS record layer sub
protocol is going to add some padding to
hide lengths and then finally at the
very bottom there's going to be the
addition of a cipher text in a Mac - to
protect the actual message that goes out
so at each level we have various proof
obligations so at the very bottom you
need to prove that the crypto that you
actually implement is is functionally
correct
and we actually also prove that it's
resistant to a class of timing side
channels so as Adam alluded to we have a
library called Hackel star that say a
library implemented in the sea like
subset of F star where we have proofs of
many crypto algorithms whose performance
compares quite favorably with the the
best handwritten sea so it's actually
interesting I hadn't seen Adams most
recent slide it looks like their version
of curve is slightly faster than ours
but this version of curve is a 64-bit
version of curve is significantly faster
than
2x faster than a handwritten version of
the same curve in OpenSSL which was a
32-bit version of openness of the curve
that was the only one that opened a cell
OpenSSL had until recently at the level
of C so using our verification
technology we were able to write 64-bit
versions of the code and and be
confident that we got it right and it's
actually this code this code from this
library this our crypto library and C is
the code that we have deployed in
Firefox so there's the elliptic curve
255 1 9 but also some other algorithms
char-char 20 and poly 1 3 or 5 are
deployed from Hackl Star in Firefox that
said are the the code generator
generated from Hackl is competitive with
with C but the best implementations are
in assembly are still significantly
faster
so using veil we have verified the
assembly code in open SSL more or less
as is and as you'd expect if you we get
performance that's that is competitive
or identical in to to the open SSL code
that we started from at the level of of
of data streams we prove that a
distributed invariant that the reader of
the the reader end of the protocol reads
from a prefix of the stream that the
writer has sent so far and in order to
send messages down the wire we need to
prove that parsing and our processing
and formatting code are correct at the
high level the main invariant that we're
after is that if the application sends a
message m and it gets formatted then
encrypted and decrypted and then parsed
the receiver receives exactly the same
message that was sent and the way we do
this is rather than writing parses and
formatters by hand which which is which
can be very tedious and error
we start from a high-level description
of the message formats from RFC text and
[Music]
synthesized via meta programming a
low-level implementation in C of of the
parcels and for matters for those
message formats so running out of time I
should wrap up so just to give you a
I'll finish with some some high level
perspective so we're building verified
components motivated primarily by HTTP
but in doing this we are components that
we produce are reusable in other
contexts as well so quick is one such
example that I've that I mentioned
briefly earlier but some of the work
that we're currently doing also involves
using our crypto libraries to build
things like verified authenticated data
structures that are used in in things
like block chains recently that we
there's some interest in using our
crypto libraries to verify the
correctness of insecurity of post
quantum crypto algorithms our verified
parser and formatted generators all the
way we're using them in TLS we also see
that they have applications in in other
secure messaging scenarios for instance
inside kernel or in communications
between VM and kernel and so on and
another high-level perspective about
about avarice is that rather than trying
to build a completely secure stack from
the ground up what we're after is is
sort of building verified islands of
trust inside the existing software
ecosystem and we think there's there's
there's value in doing that in a way
verification is a lot about the blame
game if there's we deploy our code
inside a an existing operating system
Linux or Windows or whatever the entire
system is still vulnerable to bugs but
any such bug is going to be outside of
our code if if a patch has to be shipped
it's not us that's going to be shipping
a patch so what else we'll now finding
these islands of trust in which
verification can add value is require
some some care
thinking and we think that
standards-based cryptography and
networking is a really good match for it
partly because there's a very widely
accepted common wisdom that you know
you're supposed to leave crypto to
experts and not try to roll your own so
so there's an opportunity for a
well-designed crypto library to be used
crypto library and protocol library to
be used as a drop-in replacement for the
existing code that's out there and also
I think another thing that we're quite
encouraged by is that the standards
process at at the IETF and elsewhere is
is increasingly receptive to this kind
of formal spec and and validation partly
because prior versions of of these
protocols have really been badly beaten
up by by a cycle of attacks and and and
patches so so we think there's an
opportunity there so that's it and I'll
leave you with that image it's a our
goal of trying to to build and deploy
verified components in HTTP
[Applause]
I Rebecca Wright Rutgers University
thanks for the talk so you noted at some
point that of course all of these proofs
are dependent on the model and and that
there were you know as always the
potential for attacks outside of the
model in the practical usage here do you
have you know sort of a sense whether
it's sort of inherently a cat-and-mouse
game that will continue indefinitely or
whether they're sort of in a practical
sense some kind of convergence to
capturing most of the meaningful
potential attacks I think at a certain
level there's you know at a certain
level at a high level spec about what
the protocol is trying to achieve
I think we're reaching a a sort of a
convergence but there's only always the
vulnerable the possibility of
vulnerabilities and at the lowest level
that our models don't account for so for
instance we have proofs of resistance
against a certain class of side-channel
attacks where we didn't anticipate a
specter or and meltdown either
so although we think our our code is not
for the particular kind of code that we
write it's not vulnerable to these kinds
of spectra and Multan attacks are proofs
certainly don't account for this so
those kinds of you know scenarios may
still occur in the future
at any other questions okay
well let's thank the speaker again and
that's our lunch
[Applause]